Speaker 1: One sign that things might be
about to get very dicey with Tuesday's
election is that Mypillow CEO and founder Mike
Lindell, known as Mike Pillow or simply Pillow.
Speaker 3: Over 54 countries have
now been taken by the machines.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: He is claiming that he
has a real time crime desk to monitor deviations
and anomalies of Democrats no doubt attempting
to steal Tuesday's election. Listen to what this
guy is saying. It is as scary as it is delusional.
Speaker 2: Where were you by election night?
Speaker 3: I will be in Tennessee at our
studios for frank speech. I will be there.
I'm going to help. We have two studios and
I'm going to have the real crime. The real time
crime deals with cyber guys so you can tune in
to Lindell TV and watch. And we're going to want
to see what's happening with your candidate or
whatever, if it's getting installed in real time.
Speaker 1: If it is getting stalled in real time,
Pillow's cyber
guys will tell you, folks, we are screwed.
Speaker 3: This is what's going to happen if they.
I will say when they try and steal. We're watching
from every camera angle and they're going to
do it. And when they do it, we're going to. And
on the morning of the night. Yep. If once they're
counting ones in our counter, everything's
going to stand out. And if they don't,
here's what we can pray for. We can pray
for that. The media covers the deviations
and anomalies. Yes. And I'm talking to Fox News,
Newsmax and the conservative media. They better
start reporting election prime period.
Speaker 1: Wow. That is a sick individual
or someone who has drank gallons of his own
Kool-Aid. I genuinely don't know. You know,
people write to me all the time. They
say, sir, the tears, they're crying.
They say is make pillow for real. You've
interviewed him, David. Is Mike pillow for
real when he says this stuff?
Speaker 3: We're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines.
Speaker 1: Yes. I do not know the answer.
I genuinely don't know the answer. I go back and
forth. I've now interviewed him in longer form
interviews multiple times. I do not know whether
pillow is delusional, whether he is knowingly
saying things that aren't true to rile people up.
I do not have the answer at this point in time.
Your guess is as good as mine, I would say at this
point. So we should be it. I don't. I continue to
think he might be admitting to crimes, claiming
he has cameras on the polling places. I don't
know if any of the stuff he's claiming is legal or
if it's actually happening. But we should pay very
close attention. I hope you will be with me live
on Tuesday night. That's my sincere hope. I will
be live with election results nationally. We'll be
going all night til like 8 p.m.. No, I'm kidding.
We're going. We're going to go. We're going
to go until we have definition, quite frankly,
YouTube, Twitter and Facebook. I hope you'll
be with me. And remember, subscribe on YouTube,
folks. We're pushing to two. Million YouTube
subscribers. I would love for you to hit
that subscribe button, particularly if
you're watching and don't subscribe.
There's almost 3 million of you. 3 million.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.
The David Pakman Show is funded directly by our
audience. That's just the reality. You know,
maybe I would love to have something like Steve
Bannon's gig where you've just you don't really
need to fund your show. You've got people funding
it. You don't care about your audience. We care
about the audience. We've got the bonus show.
We've got the commercial free audio and video
streams of the show. We have the members only
town halls and all of it, and you can access it
quickly, cheaply and efficiently by signing up
at Join Packman Dotcom. And for just a few more
days until the 2022 midterm election, you can
save big with the coupon code, big voting 22.